most people have no idea what attachment
is and it really is the fundamental way
that one human being
connects to another human being and
that's based on everything that happens
to us from birth
when we're small our brain says that
everything that happens to me is my
fault and some of us grow out of that
most of us don't but a little brain if
someone neglects you
if someone doesn't pay attention to you
if someone hurts you abuses you if mom
is gone
10 hours a day and you're in the care of
strangers whatever it might be what
happens is the brain says there must be
something wrong with me
deep down inside that everyone else can
see but i can't i don't know what's
wrong with me but anyone who sees this
thing
they abandon me and reject me so i need
to put up a wall and never show anybody
what's secretly
really inside of me and i'll just live
my life that way
and so we act like cardboard cutouts to
other people we don't share our needs
with people we do 10 nice things for
them hoping they'll figure out what we
secretly want on the inside but we can
never show it
that's what attachment is